two one two three
four
[Music]
it's peter france
nico perringer and ren and of course me
jake
here for another episode what's up
everyone's got the handman
peter's supposed to be playing his other
piano but he's not
it's not working he's just mean mugging
the camera instead
[Music]
guys um i don't know how we begin but we
begin
happy monday i don't know where we ended
sometimes
yeah we'll see if this comes out even
close to monday hopefully
maybe it'll be more like thursday but it
doesn't matter because we're all here
together
and uh i think that's what podcasts
and i think that's what podcasts are all
about you know hey remember
remember like two weeks ago when we had
a podcast before the election was over
like who knows who will win the election
i'm sure they'll all know by the time
this podcast comes out
that's why we invited back on four more
heteronormative white guys to talk about
politics you guys ready let's do it
let's not
uh man yeah so that was fun and
uh we still don't quite know i mean i
think we all know but maybe
we all know we all know everybody the
president
he literally tweeted last night actually
you know what you know what don't don't
don't
go don't go we don't need to talk about
where we go
no more free real estate no more free
real estate
uh so guys um
i think this would be a great
opportunity for all of us to talk about
things we've been building such as uh
ren's you know camera random nico's
camera
gun thing we literally just started that
today i'm literally wearing the shirt
that is like
me starting the whole thing i know but
it's super cool and it's something
nico's been wanting to do forever so i
figured that would be a great starting
point
yeah we're making a camera gun like wait
what the heck is a camera gun
everybody's probably wondering
you shoot shots with it yeah
you get shots with it man you get sweet
shots with it because every time you're
on set you're like
yo we gotta get the shot hey can you
just shoot that shot real quick
yeah exactly it's only normal okay so
i'll pull it up real quick run and gun
shooting in la is going to be so much
more sticky
with this now imagine a camera going
right here
it's hard to see but there's like a like
a special tripod plate that i've
mm-hmm i took an angle grinder to an old
airsoft gun and just cut it to shreds
nice so everybody listening to this is
probably wondering what the heck we're
doing everybody watching this is
probably also wondering what the heck
we're doing
no we are not trying to just make our
cameras edgier and uh more
more likely to get you know the cops
called on us that it's not someone
called
no actually he said i like that look
this is a closed
set device all right this is not a take
it out in a public street device it's a
closed set device
not
in there available there could be but
really
would there be all i know is that when
the uh
swap mags it's gonna be way more stylish
now
filmmakers filmmaking the data mags yeah
the dynamegs
um so back in the day and this is the
story i told at the beginning of the
crew video that we filmed today
back in the day when we first got the
scarlet our first red
is such an expensive camera that like we
didn't have any money to spend on
rigging
so like all we had for the camera was
like a top handle and a lens
and then the camera's body and like that
was kind of it as far as
rigging went so he'd always like put the
camera on her shoulder and almost do
like a
like a sack of potatoes like kind of
pose where like your hands resting on
the top and the camera's like
pushed into your shoulder and your left
hand is holding the the lens it's almost
like you're holding a rocket launcher or
a bazooka like that's kind of how we
held the camera
and even though it was like really
uncomfortable the shots were really
stable
and as we like started getting better
gear
it was more comfortable but it was never
quite as stable and as compact as it was
when we were doing it that method of
like the bazooka hold
so i had an idea a long time ago to like
try to set it up like
like a rifle where you have you know a
stock going into your shoulder
you have a pistol grip coming out from
underneath the camera's body
and then your left hand would be holding
the barrel of the rifle is holding the
barrel of the lens
you know the analogy is like the the
words are just too like there's too many
synonyms
between cameras and guns for it to not
make sense to build a rifle camera but
uh
you know the thing is it's three points
of contact that make it stable if you
only have two points of contact it's
like an axle you can still pivot around
it um
so three points of contact gives it
stability so you have your pistol grip
you have your shoulder stock
and then you have your other hand on the
barrel and so those three points of
contact
through you know for a rifle it makes a
rifle really stable and theoretically it
would make a camera really
stable also so it's kind of like it's
kind of like another way to approach
doing shoulder mounted camera work
but it's a little more flexible you can
pick it up and put it down a little bit
easier it's a little bit more in front
of you
like when the camera weighs like 25
pounds then putting it on your shoulder
makes sense but if your rig only weighs
five pounds or eight pounds or something
like that
holding it in front of you kind of like
a rifle it's not really all that
exerting and it just
gives you a little bit more that
flexibility for doing kind of like
handheld camera work while still making
it stable
in the process so that's where that's
what we're messing with right now
so listen is as long as you only have
two points of contact
on uh an ar-15 that has a barrel that's
long shorter than like six inches i
think
it's a pistol in the great state of
texas
and uh as long as you can fire it with
one hand it's still legal
wow that's that's all i know about three
points minimum requirement of firing it
with one hand just that it doesn't fly
out of your hand
yeah you'd hit the broad side of a barn
yep pretty much anyways
uh so three points of contact that's
right because that's what makes
that's what makes most shoulder mounted
stuff
work because you got the shoulder you
got the two hands in front
it's rigged all together and that's what
you can get
pretty good shots so i'm interested i'm
interested to see what you guys do with
it
yeah you know the theory too is like you
can pull it into your shoulder you
create a little bit like that
reverse tension which like a shoulder
mount like a regular shoulder mount
doesn't have that just it kind of rests
on you
whereas this has you kind of like
pulling against itself you know so
you're pushing against it on your
shoulder
so everything like packs in becomes a
little more stable but you know
i dreamed it ren has to make it a
reality
and there's a it's tricky because you
can't just necessarily
3d print just something all in one go
like this or maybe
you can but there's nuances to it you
know it seems like 3d printing's this
like wonderful cat challenge can just
make anything it's like well but you
still have to design it and so that's
what
the design is the problem right now it's
like sure if i had something to print i
could print it out tonight and have it
ready tomorrow but i don't have like an
actual design
yet i just got to the point where i can
start designing something
but now i'm doing this podcast so you
know
what are you thinking um basically
uh more of like a socket so the way i
cut into the gun i
took a lot first off oh my god it took a
lot of time to take that gun apart
that was that was quite the challenge
and of course i had to wear a white
t-shirt when i'm handling grease and
dirt it's got pins and stuff you could
have just removed it and had the lower
receiver
oh i took it off i'm having to angle
grind through it i only angle grinded
through the actual metal
of the of the outer lower like the frame
of the lower everything else actually
dismantled
but it wasn't as direct the two pins i
took out that was easy
but there are a bunch of other small
little things like the gun stock itself
had a screw that was going through it
into the internals of the gun
and eventually i figured out oh i got to
take that out and then there's this
other tiny pin
a tiny tiny pin yeah like a millimeter
wide
that was like the last thing keeping it
all together and once i got that out the
whole thing just came apart i was like
yes
um yeah yeah those guns have so many
parts that's why they always fail
but once i got all that uh basically the
idea was that i want to have the camera
lower
than just like to set the the plate oh
that was the other thing there's a
sackler plate that nico
uh brought up that's it's like this
whole frame in a plate that attaches the
camera
pops right in and uh instead of just
setting it on top that which would make
the camera like really top-heavy
i decided to cut into the frame to lower
it down a little bit lower center of
mass
so now it's just a matter of trying to
model and then print some sort of
uh interface uh mount between that thing
and the gun itself and i've got it
positioned so that the screw holes to
that
plate itself are accessible through the
mag well and so i just got to figure out
how to kind of just
put it together i could just like get a
big bolt and a big washer
and screw it shut and that will work
that'll work so that's that's our plan b
or maybe it's like plan e but somewhere
it's there if we need it i'll have to
get some big ass screws though
if we're gonna do that i gotta i gotta
still get some some
foot there's a place in uh no there's a
place
so there's a place in uh if you're if
you're working on cars
and stuff sometimes you need specialty
bolts and one time i was i have that old
ford
and the uh bolt that holds the
alternator into the
actual um engine cast snapped
and uh so i had this half of a
bolt like stuck into the engine cast and
i had to drill it out and then reverse
it and stuff and after that i was like
never again am i gonna get a bolt that's
just normal i need something hard so i
called around to these specialty places
there's actually a bunch of them in la
um so if you need like specialty
hardware
yeah there's yeah yeah you can get the
world's hardest bolt
i mean i just i just need a long quarter
inch
bolt yeah or screw but if you wanted to
withstand
like a traffic accident you can get that
too if there's gonna be i'm sure we'll
be throwing this camera through a track
that guy shoots around it's the only
best one
yeah an interesting
possibility with this rig is that you
could totally like
in a chaotic action scene with lots of
guns and soldiers running around it
could be an incognito camera
you just got somebody wielding the
camera gun i see
i see that's about to say what's
incognito about a gun
but i see an action scene where
everyone's got a gun yeah
interesting but yeah we've only had
we're only like one day into this
uh video so far so it could end up going
different directions down the road
ideally we actually end up shooting
something with it for this video even if
it's just like a small little uh
sequence of a few shots just to kind of
put the camera through its paces
yeah um we'll see you want us to shoot
something with the camera gun
there you go that's the title of the
video right there
it's called no safety literally there's
no safety trigger
that's the title of the the video in the
video is called
no safety yeah dude i carry a clip
loaded in my playback it's just like
yeah so it's hot the moment i hit the
record can you can you mod the camera so
that the
uh data magazine goes through the actual
magazine receiver
i wish no and then you you put a huge
one on there so you have like 10
terabytes of data
and you can you unclip it just like a
real magazine
yeah or if you get get it set up with
the red you could use the red mags go in
like the little baby
thin thing and then send it to uh like a
sarah
they have that sarah coding or terra
coating or whatever it's called that
really fancy gun coating
and you can get it you can get painted
in all these ridiculous colors
so we should send it off to get painted
in like a really really fancy paint job
gold and black they could do it by the
end of this week lightning
yeah no problem really amazing it would
cost
way more than it's worth but
also both dean and nick have separately
suggested that i
somehow turned the trigger into like a
record button so you're like oh that'd
be great
shooting but i don't know how to do that
right now
yeah i think there's a technically a
remote record
like protocol that a lot of cameras
share where if you just give it a
certain electrical signal
across a certain port you'll just enable
recording
okay blackmagic has that i can maybe
wire that up to like a little button
and put a button in place for the
triggers on amazon for like five bucks
yeah we could always just say we did
when it we ever done that we never do
that we always do it for now with
something like that
that was something like that that would
need to function for real
yeah also i keep uh seeing out of the
corner of my eye uh
did you model a camera and eyeball
camera
peter peter yeah where oh is that on
next computer yeah it's on the computer
over there
and it looks exactly like the original
uh what was it samsung galaxy 360 camera
oh yeah it looks exactly like that
i was just trying to make like an apple
made an eyeball what it would look like
i mean it's pretty spot on
that video is coming out tomorrow so by
the time this podcast comes out it'll
have just come out
so hell yeah i was wondering about that
what's going on there
what's going on there well yeah with the
i camera i think
i think it's done
uh so peter myself and nick
i've been working on this video last
week where
it was it's just a question i had you
know in the back my mind which was
what are the specs of your eye like you
know does your eye see an 8k
does it see in 16k does it see you know
is it 10 bit
like what the heck if your eye was a
camera what would the specs be
you know if you want to make a camera
better than your eye what would you what
would have to be in it
um and so that you know eventually we
had a time here we could record a crew
video
um about something like that and did
some research and
did some experiments and and we
discovered what it would take to make an
eye camera
um so peter and i have a little skit
going where we're acting like
he's peter jobs i'm niko wozniak we're
launching the i camera
uh because the problem is like we're
trying to make cameras and we weren't
successful then we realized it's because
everybody has a camera in their head
so we need to make a camera that's
better than that one if we're gonna sell
these cameras
and hence the eye camera was born the ii
camera the eye
camera
yeah nico was doing all the heavy
lifting i was just there to go whoa
yeah it's cool
we had a good repertoire going on yeah
yeah i mean hey your jobs impression was
actually pretty solid so
you know the bow and the walk and
whatnot you did that for uh
you did that for a brand integration too
the other day yeah i don't know how that
one's gonna turn out that was super
weird
yesterday i think we already released it
did we no i think it's coming out with
the eye video oh okay
yeah i don't think i i haven't seen it
yet okay yeah it's like me just hanging
out in
the broom closet i was a big fan i was a
big fan
especially with the b-roll did you see
nick intercut the b-roll of like people
at uh iphone you know like
conventions like an apple keynote yeah
keynote
yeah sweet yeah that was super funny
those raycons
yeah um so we got the eye camera
now uh nico how many stops does it need
did you say
to to beat the human eye like 16 or is
it nobody
20 over 20 stops you need basically 21
stops or so
okay to be at the level of like the
mechanics of the human eye but then like
we have really nice neural net
processing uh behind all our images
which
interestingly enough uh apple is doing
their iphone now with the iphone 12
there's neural processing on all the
photos you take
and the videos it's pretty crazy what is
that um
so you guys have seen like i mean all
everybody here on this podcast right now
you've seen the
like the videos or something like up
rez's old footage or runs like an old
image you know thing through like a
image up rezzer and he uses an ai to
upskill that stuff
what what or you know uh
and videos i'm sorry i'm playing that
was
a bad joke well maybe
um so so
you've seen maybe nvidia oh i get it
when you're saying wren sorry i'm just
in a very literal state of mind right
now
maybe uh i'm sure people are familiar
with nvidia's demonstration of i think
it's like dlss where like it renders
like a 720p
image and it upscales it to 4k um
yeah so apple's doing something similar
in their phone
because they have a standardized you
know lens and a sensor
they can really go hard in profiling
their camera and how it acts so for
example
you take that sensor in that lens take a
picture at regular exposure in a spot
turn all the lights off and give it a
little bit of light crank the gain take
another picture
and now you have a ground truth of like
here's a picture without any noise all
clear
and here's a here's one with a bunch of
noise because the gain is boosted way
high
and then you can use an ai to try to
match those two um since you can feed it
the correct answer
after it sees the noisy one and tries to
guess its own answer got it
it's a really it's a really good way to
do uh you know uh deep learning is to
have like a set of correct answers the
computer tries to guess and you can look
at the correct answers and compare the
two
and then the more correct it is the the
more you encourage it to keep going down
that path of development
um yeah so apple's basically been doing
this for all their stuff because
everything's you know all built into the
phone it's all profiled
um so now there's like you know ai based
noise removal there's ai based up resin
happening there's ai-based like image
clarity and enhancements going on
in like it's very very subtle and
there's like certain cues to look for
and the thing that i noticed
was my eyelashes being really defined in
the selfie camera
when it was low light like you can see
some of the like the compression
blocking and some of the
color splotchiness but then i'd have
eyelashes and they'd be crisp and i'd be
like that's weird
i was just seeing this detail yeah it's
trained on people because
it's known it goes like okay this is the
part that would usually be an eyelash
it's a little bit of a blurry pixel now
but let's enhance it to what it should
be and that's what's going on it's very
subtle
i mean the pictures look great um but
it's interesting just
see a dedicated ai filter working on
every picture you have now
does it do that locally or is it using a
cloud for that
no it doesn't locally part of the chip
on the iphone is dedicated
to running uh machine learning models
yeah
and doing it quickly honestly like the
way to go
it's really smart i mean that's the
thing about machine learning models
right is that it takes a lot of
processing power to create them but then
not that much to run them after they're
created right
exactly yeah training them is the hard
part it's running them it's
i mean granted you can make a clunky
model that's hard to run but like
generally speaking running them is much
much faster than training them
plus the advantage of running it on a
dedicated processor for that is that
it's much more energy efficient it's
going to use far less
you know battery power because i
remember back when like uh the iphone
was first a thing
and it would die so quickly because
the gps was running off of the processor
and and
anytime you're using google maps your
battery would die like 10 times faster
and so after like another
one or two generations of phones they
dedicated an entire different chip just
to running gps
processing and that like increased
battery uh
efficiency by like dramatically
yeah this is some pretty wild stuff
that's going on in phones
right now like yeah yeah oh also also uh
nico uh so this is your first new phone
in three years you had the 10 the
original 10.
the original 10. yeah and now you're on
the 12. so you now have a wide-angle
camera
on your on your phone yeah it's great i
love the wide-angle camera it's like
i'm jealous i have like the 10s max or
whatever so i don't have that
yeah man i've been missing it you know
it's uh
you know at this point in time like my
phone's just my baby picture camera i
use it to take pictures of my baby
that's pretty much
mostly all i do with it that and play
civilization and talking discord
you know so and send text messages so
it's like
i hate that wide-angle camera i was just
like i was feeling it like i was like
i'm trying to get these pictures and i
can't get them i'm too close i can't
back up far enough the walls are
i live in a city my buildings are too
small you know
so yeah it's it's really nice the wide
angle just opens up so many things i
i swear in within 10 years
apple will make normal cameras like
dslrs and all that just to make them
obsolete
don't get me wrong they'll still be like
you know just like the people that buy
records they'll still be people that buy
dslrs and specialty jobs and all that
kind of stuff but
generally speaking i think the
attraction for just
the hobbyist and like even maybe the
prosumers to go with a dslr
or even like a cinema camera like the
black magic pocket or something it just
can be wiped away after apple's done
like with their stuff
yeah because it's like the the main
mainstay of having like
solid big pieces of glass for lenses and
and whatnot is that you have
it's the actual physics of an aperture
being a certain size
accepting more light and and having like
that depth of field and whatnot
uh you're never able to capture that
with the tiny lenses that are on our
cameras
however with all of the crazy uh
processing going on with these photos
now they're able to detect depth and
just simulate depth of field
and bokeh in all of your shots from now
on so at a certain point it's like i bet
you'll see like a tiny little lens
tiny little sensor capturing something
that's just as good as a big lens and
big sensor with proper depth of field
yeah probably at a certain point just
like with resolution you know it got to
a point where
you just couldn't tell whether
something's i mean after 4k
you know you just can't really can't
really tell either way
yeah it i could see that with with image
processing
i mean it'll eventually get good enough
um
yeah yeah that's
the thing for me would be the um the
actual physical form of it
because it's easier when you can attach
you know handles
and put it in a frame and uh
you know you've got the actual form
factor of a camera
so that's the main thing for a phone
right now is that it
it doesn't it doesn't you have to hold
it like this and you kind of have to
hold it daintily and you
put a piece of plastic on it that pops
out that's attached with glue it's just
it's still kind of you know it's still
kind of janky
um i i don't know how you get past that
i guess you you could
you could build some kind of aftermarket
box
true but there's a couple things like
one
like this lens profile is so tiny like i
can get this like
on a table you know and get a shot from
like on the table like yeah if i wanted
to do
like you know a point of view of this
battery i can actually get that because
the phone is so tiny or things even just
like holding it like out a window or
like getting other cool angles with it
it's very easy to maneuver so on one
hand the tininess counts against it but
on the other hand
it's also really nice for certain angles
yeah it's so light too i mean you can
always rig it up you could rig up a
phone
or you put a hunky case for it you know
put on a glove
and the glove has a stabilizer and the
it just balances it wherever you move it
yeah
yeah that would actually be pretty sweet
maybe you should come up with that next
red
after you print the uh run after you
print the camera gun
peter yeah thanks for your input peter
hello it's that time in the episode
where i tell you about today's sponsor
story blocks now if you guys don't know
who they are that means you probably
haven't listened to this podcast very
much because they sponsor us
all the time so i want to tell you who
they are not only because they sponsor
the podcast
but also because we use them here at
corridor digital for
all of our stock asset needs storyblocks
is the complete stock solution
for creators and businesses alike when
they're looking for high quality
video images and sound and music
for all the things that they're creating
they offer royalty-free plans
meaning that you can download from their
site and use it in things that you are
monetizing or commercial projects that
you are using or creating
for other clients this is great because
you don't have to worry about
the logistics of whether or not you need
to pay a royalty whether you paid for
the right subscription to get the
royalty plan
all you do is you go on storybox and you
sign up for the unlimited all-access
plan
this gives you access to a virtually
unlimited
library of stock assets we use it for
video and b-roll
we use it for motion graphics we use it
for images and the best part about the
unlimited all-access plan
is that you can download as much as you
want whenever you want and use it
wherever you want this is a huge asset
for us so if you're just an individual
creator
or you're a creative agency or a whole
business it doesn't matter
this is a great tool to have in your
tool kit and once again a huge thanks to
them for sponsoring this podcast
continually because
honestly it wouldn't be possible for us
to take the time to produce it
if it wasn't for them so head on over to
storyblocks.com
court or cast to check out more that's
corridorcast and um well you're gonna
love it
okay back to the episode let's go you
know i'm kind of sad that in like
popular culture science fiction like
little propellers and little rocket
engines are like no longer considered
like a viable way to maneuver your
imaginary vehicles
you know it's like it's too like i was
like propellers don't work like that you
know like if you had like a plane with
100 propellers on the top or like you
know a battleship that like
you know had like eight little rockets
that like you know pushed it along like
they don't do that anymore it's always
like anti-gravity or you know
everybody's too wise about propellers
and rockets these days and eventually
they'll get wise about anti-gravity
yeah it'll be the same stick and then
it'll be something else
you know what we gotta do well i gotta
make a
giant drone ship there you go
okay i'm listening that's it that's the
idea
you know what we gotta do man okay i got
a great idea we gotta make a giant
drone ship okay but it'll it won't be
powered by propellers it'll be powered
by anti-gravity man
people have done it people have like
built chairs with like 50 dji drones
around them to lift them into the air
well they're not dji drones they're uh
they're high-powered motors but yeah
okay i've
actually looked into this quite a bit
because i would love to be able to
actually pilot my own drone with my body
in it
um and it's like it's the sort of thing
that we can do today with current
technology people have done it already
uh yeah on top of that
uh there i want to be able to fly a
drone that can also swim
you know like because uh i've seen a
video uh i think it was from
jay true i forget who uh made the video
um of like a drone on the bottom of a
pool
and if it the propellers turn on it
floats up to the top of the pool
leaves it and then flies away whoa yeah
i guess that could work that's cause i
mean as long as you waterproof all the
electronics the motors there's no
electronics in a motor
it's just wires uh they can get wet
that's no big deal
as long as you waterproof all everything
that's you know a circuit you can have
it go under water
so that's some that's something that i
kind of want to try is maybe add like a
fifth propeller on the back that's just
like a little impeller to make it go
forward
oh speaking of flying stuff uh i've got
a question you know how you
you know how you flew that jet pack yeah
um so for those of you who don't know
ren last year
was it last year yeah it was last
december wren flew a jet pack
at the lax airport was it it wasn't lax
oh where was it it was like it uh in
ventura
okay it was like really far away from
iliac you were in an airplane hangar
yes okay so i tried i saw an
article did you did you see that article
i shared with you
i think i know what you talked about it
was a couple weeks ago and i shared with
you an article where
there had been sightings right of people
at
lax being like yeah we saw this we saw
somebody in a jet pack again today we
don't know what's going on
um yes i looked into that um okay
currently no one knows what it is
because it couldn't have been a jet pack
it definitely wasn't any of the jet
packs that
anyone knows of currently because a jet
pack can fail
yeah and you fall right and if you're
then because i
i asked the dude who invented the jet
pack that i tried out was like how high
can it go and he's like
however high as i want it to go
i can go to the atmosphere or the
stratosphere if i want to but like
you know if it it fails a lot and if it
fails if i'm anywhere above like 15 feet
you're gonna break some legs
right so they rarely fly above like
10-15 feet right unless they're over
water and then they never go above like
40 50 but still
so uh that sighting came from i think
pilots
uh flying actual airliners as opposed to
uh
uh pedestrians or whatever and they're
seeing them at like 3000 feet altitude
which is like really high up um
and then it was just like a one and done
thing we were like that's a weird thing
but then it happened again
like a month later someone saw saw the
same thing again
no one still knows what that was or what
it is or what's going on
that person fell into the pacific ocean
and
they are no longer with us it was
hypothesized that maybe it was like a
mannequin on a drone
yeah oh that's a boring explanation
what about just the one that makes sense
it or it was a person who was just dumb
enough
the thing i don't i don't know how you
could be smart enough to make a jet pack
but then dumb enough to fly at that high
without knowing that if you had some
fail safe i mean that's superhero on our
hands
maybe we have a flying man on our hands
we've gotta
call the authorities we've got a flying
man on our hands an iron
man do you think the pilots were just
flying along he's like
is that a guy is that a guy
right there hey frank frank is that a
guy
is that a guy wait is it this is a
throwback reference i don't think
anyone's gonna get it hold on hold on
okay
i got uh okay i got it let me send that
to the wife
okay hey honey
hey is this a guy i mean
dude i who knows i could see somebody
doing that though i could see somebody
being like
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna be the first
one and then iron man is gonna happen to
me yeah
but here's the thing if someone's doing
that and they're flying that high up
they're not gonna do it near an airport
you would think but who
who would you know like no one would fly
anything near an airport like that it's
incredibly reckless and dangerous right
yeah but it's hard to be that smart in
that dome at the same time yeah exactly
unless you're a billionaire
prize and you buy your tag
and you own your tech yeah uh
yeah unless you're an iron man in which
case
you know i don't know maybe you could do
it
maybe it was a mannequin on a drone but
still even even in the event that it was
a mannequin flying a drone
you're still dealing with a person or a
a drone
flying a mannequin sorry uh you're still
dealing with a situation where
somebody's flying that close to an
airport
recklessly yep so i i'd say yeah it's
more likely that it's that because
that's way more accessible to an idiot
but i mean the faa is all over this
right now they are investigating the
hell out of this right now
oh i'm sure i'm sure they're super
excited about it they're like
guys planes have been taking off and
landing with almost 100 consistency for
the last 80 years
okay and now there's a mannequin or a
man
flying around dude it's just jeff bezos
it's obviously just jeff bezos it's just
jeff
old jeff you know
your old pal jeff up there
he left the honda accord now he's up in
the sky
flying around jeff bezos drives a honda
accord
no he used to though when amazon was
like a
a young company and he did his first
like 60 minutes
interview um they they were driving
around in a
uh like a honda civic or something that
that was like basically it was like
yours it was same era
it was late 90s uh so you're saying like
i'm like jeff bezos and
yeah yeah exactly yeah that's where yeah
gotcha now he drives a tesla
no way he draws a jet pack no he's
covered this yeah
yeah have you been enjoying that model y
by the way to the model y is
the best car i've ever driven straight
up
are you worried about taking control of
you
and driving off somewhere no not at all
roll over okay
because when there was one time ren it
wouldn't move until ren put his seat
belt on and i was concerned
what when was that remember when we were
at the range
and we were filming bosstown dynamics
and you got him to move it
and you went and it wouldn't move in
reverse until you put the seat belt on
okay that is actually something it does
do and it's really annoying because i
get home
and my if my gate is closed i have to
get out because i back into my driveways
i have to get out open the gate
and i get back into my car to pull into
the the driveway and i never put on my
seatbelt because i'm going in a driveway
so i go about four feet and then the car
just lurches to a stop i'm like
huh and it's like and it's like put your
seatbelt on
we're preventing a roll away it's in
danger like what oh
roll away you should just 3d print a
little seat buckle and just put it in
that's way more work than listen i don't
have to worry about taking it out and
then
storing it in this opening how are you
going to ghost ride the whip if you
can't get out of your tesla while it's
driving
autonomously ghost ride the wheel i mean
people have tried that people have
actually succeeded in doing that before
getting
you know find tremendous amounts of
money
with a manager illegal uh i forget how
they did it but basically the dude like
he puts a weight on the steering wheel
and some sort of weight on the seat
to fool anything he's still there i
think he was like sitting on the seat
belt
and then he just got up and got in like
the back seat i was just going down the
highway and someone got a video of him
doing that
yeah i don't want to think he even got
it i think it was it i think it was in
england it was in the uk i believe and i
think it got arrested
yeah don't do that i forget i forget
where
but it was yeah super not okay we could
totally do that on
someone's land though that would be a
lot of fun
i think i mean you could have a car
drive itself on someone's property
yeah anyways need like road uh
like road maps or road vectors to like
truly do autonomous driving though
i'm not sure what you mean by that well
i guess it does it does the parking lot
summon thing but like when you're on a
road i thought the tesla kind of checked
in with the
like known maps uh to like okay there
should be like a 15 degree curve coming
up here oh yeah absolutely so if
if you're on private property and you
didn't have that then theoretically the
tesla wouldn't be able to
follow the roads correctly uh
potentially i mean what it's still doing
is this reading all the cameras you know
uh
tesla's uh yeah uh standpoint on this is
that like all right
people can drive cars using two cameras
as inputs
going back to the video the crew video
you guys were making earlier so it's
like if we can do that
with just two cameras a car should be
able to do with eight cameras radar and
sonar
yeah as opposed to how everyone else is
doing self-driving cars which is using a
lidar scanner actually taking
creating like a real-time 3d scan of the
environment um
but there's a lot of downsides of that
it like doesn't work in rain or fog
um yeah so
the tesla doesn't have lidar either just
says radar and sonar correct yeah and
the sonar is only effective up to like
five feet around the car like a
circumference around the car and then
the radar
is like 500 feet in front of you but not
behind or to the sides
so the sonar is what the what it uses to
tell if you're about to like bump your
door on a guard exactly yeah when it
starts popping up like how many inches
away from
something i love that feature it's so
good
he's like gas motors aside like there's
so many other like little things about
cars that they just
rethought like there's not this legacy
of like well we have 40 years of making
this car body it's got to have these
things in it
like that i just i super appreciate in
in the model why you know everything
from like
the wireless phone charger built into
like the console where you put your
phone so like any time you set your
phone down there it starts charging it's
like
even i don't have you can get it i'm
sure
it's a little like yeah you just
swapping plates or whatever but i'm like
i don't want to pay 150 bucks for this
little upgrade
yeah and then things like via the phone
key is like another one
like i'm surprised that maybe maybe cars
are like this these days but i don't
think so but i'm surprised
more cars don't have a second battery
for running your electronics at this
point
like why is why are all the cars
electronics still running off the 12
volt battery meant for starting your
engine
like make a separate like lipo battery
bank for your car to just run things
like your radio
and like your bluetooth receivers and
all the things that
make your car smart that like you should
end up make independent of your motor
having to run you know like why don't
they do that
it seems like that's a good idea for
sure but you know it's like truly ironic
nico
a tesla maybe not the model y i'm but
i'm pretty sure that is still the case
all of the electronics all like the
computer the software all that stuff
run off of an a lead acid 12-volt
battery a regular run-of-the-mill car
battery
is actually inside a tesla and that's
what all the electronics are run off of
what really yep yep
travel in paradise guys and then that
battery is recharged
somebody helped niko
[Laughter]
you could also hack into any model 3 or
model y
you know that little circle on the front
of your car that little like little
circle thing oh wait it's like the
panel it's like a little it's a little
circle about this big like
front yeah you could actually poke into
that and pull out two wires and if you
connect a nine volt battery to it it'll
open your hood
oh really yeah so anyone can open
anyone's hood if you have a nine volt
battery
but then of course you know you're on
camera because teslas are recording four
different camera
feeds at all times and the alarm would
go off
and all the time you got the uh a usb
stick so yeah
you already got the you already got the
mask on okay because it's covered so
then now you just pull out your phone
and the alarm's going off and you're
like
you just point you just wear like a nice
button up with like some slacks so
people are like oh yeah
that guy owns that car and then you're
like you're like looking at your phone
like yeah if people are looking at you i
don't know
i'm trying to fix it i don't know i'm
calling somebody right now yeah sorry
hey sorry and then your buddy is just
there like ripping out all the
components
i mean jake i've actually thought about
that before like not actually
following through on it but i've thought
about like you know
what if what if i decided to you know
just rob this tesla like
how would i go about doing a dream right
it doesn't cost anything
uh yeah so no there's a huge problem
with uh a lot of different
functionalities like that uh with these
ford f-150s that i got there's like this
really
easy way to crack into the to the cabins
and so out here there's so tell me more
oh there's so damn many of them out here
all you need is a phillips head
screwdriver and basically a hammer
and then you can pop the you can get
right into them and so
there's so many of them out here like
people are always breaking into them for
all kinds of nonsense yeah so i'm super
paranoid about that now
um blocks are just an illusion of
security
they are a lock only keeps an honest man
honest i i once heard it
that's pretty good so but yeah the funny
thing about locks
sorry that's it
yeah yeah so um it's you know there's
always some way to
to do a hack or you know uh do you
remember when we were in high school
nico those kids got busted
uh stealing cars because they were
cracking into they had this way to you
basically
crack the like third panel in a window
and then you open it and then they were
like they were like
hammering into the top of the steering
column and then like hot wiring them and
enjoy riding them yeah uh that was a
thing for a while
i wasn't a part of it but i heard about
it i just you know
and uh you have heard of that i heard
about it
i i didn't know an awful lot about the
process yeah yeah
yeah they popped that one window and
they got in the car
specific models from 94 to 99 you know
um no so yeah
i think they all got arrested i don't
know
peter your video legged out really hard
for a second there so like
you just end up with like really bad
comedic timing on that green water joke
[Laughter]
actually my wi-fi was fine i just have
awful comedic timing
this is so good man happens to be the
best do you guys want to talk about
population one
yeah yeah
you've been playing a little bit more
you finally got to work and you've been
playing
okay first like week i tried to play
there were so many bugs like i couldn't
turn my clips wouldn't go in my [ __ ]
camera would stay in the same place when
i moved my head but uh they finally
fixed all of it are you sure it wasn't
your wi-fi
no it might have been one wi-fi hey but
i upgraded my router and modem so now i
don't have mcdonald's wi-fi anymore
sick i called them i was like hey i'm
supposed to be getting like 300 megabits
i'm getting like three
and they were like oh dude your router
is like 15 years old
i was like oh cool come on there's your
problem right there
let me tell you something there's the
problem right there yep so nico and i
have been playing population one which
is a vr
battle royale game we've been playing it
on the quest 2
and it has honestly been one of the best
like vr experiences just for like
quick fun uh multiplayer uh shooter type
fun
stuff um it does help
to the point that i don't want to play
anymore unless i'm playing with uh
one of you guys because i usually end up
getting paired with two guys who are
brand new to the game and we end up
losing i'm like well this sucks
but so peter you're playing on the vive
pro with the
lighthouse tracking and all that stuff
so it's not made for the vive pro but it
does work
on it like it was made for oculus right
it was made for
yeah but this game has been this has
been in development for like two years
they announced it like two years ago and
so
then the quest came out and they they
actually pivoted to make it
uh work on the quest and then the quest
too so actually if you're playing on it
from the computer
your graphics are going to be better
than what we're seeing on the quest
interesting um but that being said i
have not had any complaints about the
graphics in this game even though it's
like i guess
technically they're low-fi textured like
simplistic
it is kind of fortnitey in style but
there's something just so satisfying
about just like
climbing something looking around
jumping off and flying there
and then putting on a gun and then just
like that's very freeing
yeah they did uh they did a really good
job of like embracing
like you know this is an ethos that
brian brought to like bone works to a
certain degree too which is like vr
shouldn't just be about
fully simulating reality it should be
about giving you
the access to the reality of your dreams
you know having levitation having flying
having infinite strength like all these
things you want to enable some of that
to make it like truly fun
because otherwise why go into vr i can
pick up an object and drop it in real
life and
marvel at the physics of that you know
i do that all the time and
you know the population one brings to
life you know a lot of
types of gameplay that you really can
only have in vr but it's simplified
enough and like
babyfied enough that like you know you
can still do it in what is not you know
it's not a perfect representation of
reality it's it's definitely still a
proximity of it so
things like reloading a gun it's not
like a fine-tuned thing it's just a
you know you just basically do two
movements and you're done but you still
have to do a movement to reload it still
requires a physical reaction and the
weird thing about
population one compared to like shooters
on the computer for myself
is i'm way more situationally aware
and spatially aware in vr than pop one
than i am like on the computer playing a
shooter
it's weird like i know way more like
about where people are positioned how
they're moving like it just it's a weird
sense where it's like
amazed because i spent more time in vr
over the past few years but like
it my brain clicks with that information
so much better so when i get into a
gunfight
like i'm way more deadly compared to a
gunfight i like when i'm playing mouse
and keyboard
probably way more deadly inputs that you
would get you know just in real life and
your brain has
so much more power to process that than
process what's on a screen so it kind of
makes sense it's more intuitive
and there's the depth factor yeah you
know like being able to see depth
just from from two eyes i've started
experimenting with making 3d video
we have like the insta 360 evo camera
which is basically a 360 camera
that literally unfolds to become two 180
degree cameras
that are perfectly distanced at the same
distance as our eyeballs
so that like it records video and when
you review it back
in a vr headset it literally looks like
you're seeing real life it's pretty nuts
so i threw it on my
my racing drone and like flew around a
park and it's like
i'm flying that's what i was about to
say is wren showed me that video and my
whole expression the entire time was
just oh
i also took it on a one-wheel ride and
that was a lot of fun uh it works
it works really well but it's like it's
shooting at 5k
i mean between shared between the two
images so it's like 5k is not enough
for for like a vr video maybe not like
360 video in my opinion completely
overrated if i'm in a vr headset i'm
going to watch something
put it in front of me i don't care
what's behind me don't don't waste your
pixels on all that stuff
i just want to see 3d 180 video in front
of me
uh and i think it's yeah it's the way to
go so i think we have to be at least 8k
before it starts getting like
8k like 60fps minimum for that sort of
thing
to be like good well you have like a
lower frame rate higher resolution mode
on that right
what you're showing me one video that
had a lower frame rate oh yes
okay so
no i i in in my experiments i had one
that was shooting like
5k at 30 fps and then another one that
was shooting 4k at
50 fps oh okay and the 4k 50 fps
looks significantly better because that
temporal resolution is a big deal
it's like at 30fps you know it might
look more cinematic or maybe not 30 but
you know 24.
but when you're immersed in something
you don't want to have that stuttery
feel it's really like jarring to watch
so you want to have as high frame rate
as possible yeah it looked much better
with the high frame rate even though it
was
less resolution exactly yeah hey ren
um you get a lot of questions from
people looking to
uh to do what you do with their life
um we get we i should actually send some
some more of these to you because we get
we get emails every like
every day of people asking hey i want to
do
you know what you guys do i just don't
know how
um is this this is a skillshare segue
no this is not not the same thing
this is this is a legit segue
okay okay i have a legit question so um
and spencer's been asked this too
because spencer's kind of a macgyver
of of technology and and trait um
what's what do you think the best most
direct path is for someone to be able to
do relatively the same thing as what you
do in your life
and not necessarily the same path that
you took but like
gotta go to nam
oh go go to nam back in nam is where i
got these skills
that's true yeah ren did live in vietnam
um which is completely irrelevant
but uh i mean it's weird i don't know
anyone else who
who does what i do like not even anyone
here at corridor
does what i do you know like right
i i don't know when you say like are you
talking about being a youtuber
making videos being like a visual
effects artist because i'd say those are
two different things
uh or like any number of other things
that we do here like
what's the best that's yeah that's
that's a good uh uh
combination of of traits i think like
do you need a dad that's a geologist do
you need to like
you know what do you did he did you
absorb information from him that got you
like inspired to do stuff
or like did you did you just were you
like you know what
engineering then vfx and then i'm good
to go
yeah i mean the engineering thing was
just like that's i mean my
my brain works at like an engineer brain
would i guess
uh but there's a huge amount of
crossover between visual effects
and and engineering because it's all
problem solving
uh i've just always been way more of
like visually based
in how i like view the world and think
about problems so
it was like when i was actually like
finishing up my engineering degree like
literally my final semester my last year
that i was like
i don't want to do engineering
[Laughter]
but it wasn't so much that i didn't want
to do it as much as i was really falling
in love with you know making youtube
videos and and
visual effects and then this new channel
came out out of nowhere called corridor
digital and
uploaded like this random like vfx
uh test of like
from green side right with the tv coming
out of the floor yep maybe
yeah yeah and there's like the the tail
storm
on the on the street uh you saying the
building's not up to code as you bonked
into it
like anyway this is all around the same
time as like freddie and whatnot and
uh i was just before that i was also
discovering visual effects so it was all
like hobby based
and so it was all stuff i taught myself
and when i say that there's crossover
between that and
uh engineering it's like technically i'm
not i've never really applied anything i
learned in engineering directly to
vfx but it does help with like learning
how to work hard and problem solve and
just like persevere through like late
nights and stuff like that
but yeah and then also i guess the oh go
ahead well yeah i guess what i'm saying
is that like
all of the resources are out there for
you to learn to do whatever it is you
want to do
like it doesn't matter what it is you
could probably find some sort of
resource
for free chances are if not maybe it
costs a little bit of money for like
some sort of course or whatever
uh but yeah it's like you combine that
with passion that is so intense it
borderlines
on obsession i think you have to have a
little bit of obsession to really make
it in
in some of these fields i agree and it's
like you know obsession isn't exactly
healthy
and at the same time so to define i
guess what i consider to be obsession
it's it's when you take something that
is of interest to you like a hobby
but then you just like you you just
focus on it
and it's it's the only thing you care
about in your life you're not watching
movies
or video games you don't have any sort
of like side things you do on the side
like
all of your spare time is doing this one
thing and ideally
all of your like pro time is also doing
that same thing like back in the
uh like early 2010s like right around
when i graduated college and i was like
focusing on this stuff like i would
spend
all day every day just focusing on
learning how to do visual effects
coming up with uh ideas that i can try
to actually follow through on because
it's one thing to study tutorials and
like
learn and read everything you can but
it's another to actually apply that
stuff and the only way to apply it is to
like pick something you're going to try
to do and just work your butt off to try
to achieve that
and it's it's all about just like all
right i have no idea how to do this but
the process of getting to that point is
so
valuable and then it's like okay once
you've done that then it's the next
thing and that's basically what all
youtube is is just doing that over and
over and over again you make a new video
make another new video do it again rinse
repeat you're in you're out
i mean that's just really echoes my
experience and i bet it it sounds like
it echoes peters and jake's experience
too i mean i think that's
what you're saying there's kind of the
core truth of uh anybody who's really
trying to go out and pursue something
that requires you to be unique is you
have to be unique
and really the only way to be unique at
something is to like truly dedicate
yourself to something
and develop it and make it yours which
is not something that happens
casually exactly flippantly i think
that's one of the hardest things
especially for
if you're coming out the gate you know
from high school or college and you're
trying to
you're trying to pick because uh once
you start
doing that the the other doorways of
your life
have to close you know in order for you
to be obsessed at one thing you have to
close the door off
to five other things yeah but but it
also that
that uh that also narrows your focus too
so that's not necessarily a bad thing
because it narrows your focus
it allows you to simply and more
efficiently focus
on on on something and ideally that
something is
taking all the other five things that
you could be doing and giving you
something more rewarding
as a result of it and that's different
for everybody but i almost flunked out
of college
due to this obsession yeah like i i was
put on
uh academic probation twice in college
for like getting bad grades like i think
i got a couple d's
like i wasn't very good at like advanced
calculus
yeah it was it was hard and and so but
it was like but it was because
i mean partly because i was you know
playing halo with all my my roommates
and whatnot but also because i was
obsessed with like just learning as much
as i could about filmmaking and visual
effects
i was just absorbing as much information
as i could and as a result my studies
that i was paying tuition to do
were suffering and so at a certain point
i had to realize i had to stop doing all
this so i could
focus on finishing engineering otherwise
i would lose probably both and so yeah
like you're saying
when if you're going to have this one
door open your other doors are closing
around you
right and i realized okay this is a fun
side door but i have to close it to make
sure this main door stays open
right it really helps too when you love
it like
it sounds like you really loved it and
so you didn't have a problem dedicating
all your time to it and honestly
i feel like that's such a gift more than
anything is to love the thing that
you're doing because then all the work
you're doing
doesn't feel as much like work i guess
that's where i like to put it yeah i
guess
that's where like the passion side of
things comes in because it's like it's
obsession yeah but passion is
obsession with love right man this is a
poetic podcast
yeah there's a it's a it's a balance too
because you
i mean rocks always keep an honest man
honest
[Laughter]
um no i almost flunked out of law school
because of it too
i didn't go to college yeah peter just
stopped going
yeah peter just stopped going but you
stopped at the worst time dude
because this is the best time
can you imagine paying 60 grand a year
for college right now and all you're
getting is zoom classes
it's like dude i can watch youtube
tutorials and
make money like i think a lot of people
are
right now honestly oh that's rough
dude my uh i might be outing him a
little bit here but one of the guys i
raced with from race to the rail
um i'm not gonna say his name just to
make it a little harder anyway he's a
kid uh very very good at one wheeling
and him and i uh bonded over batteries
uh like he he's he loves to take apart
uh the one wheel and like sell off parts
and like
remake battery packs and stuff like that
uh
and and so he was telling me about this
last semester of school
where it was all zoom based and he
basically just checked out
he like he would like turn it on so that
he was like technically like
you know in class but he was just doing
he was just tinkering off to the side so
he wasn't
that whole last semester of class like
he didn't pay attention at all
wait is he high school or college he's a
call a high school kid
um but he's also a very very smart dude
i don't think he's really missing out
too much
on that but i mean you know whatever so
instead he's just having a thriving
business
making thousands of dollars as a
freaking 15 year old high school kid
more power to him like a lot lots of
balance
yeah it's important if you're going to
if you're going to check out
you have to be like you have to be
dedicating your time to something you
know your passion
your your obsession like that's you know
if you're just going to sit there and
play video games
i mean maybe if you're doing a pro you
know if you're professional playing
video games video games are where
it gets little little
there's a big difference between there's
a big big difference between not
not going because you're you're starting
your own business which is effectively
what that kid's doing
yeah or like you know uh
brandon was uh had finished and he was
already doing
he was already like scheduled and slated
to go into the field that he
wanted to do peter same thing wren you
were
effectively training yourself to do all
the skills to
to do what you do now there's a huge
difference between that and just being
like well
school's for idiots so you know
yeah like if i and sometimes you know
for people that
are wondering about like hey maybe you
haven't found that thing yet
sometimes you find something and then
you become passionate about it because
you start to see how it affects
the rest of the world around you you
know and you might not have seen that at
the beginning but once you know
once you uncover that rock or two and
you're like oh hey actually
that part about what i'm doing right now
actually
i really like that what's what's
underneath there
and then you start to turn over the you
start to walk through those doors and
you start to see oh how how it comes
back or opens up these other doors into
all these other things
um so peter i got a question for you as
someone who's
just finished their run at college what
advice would you have
for other people that are interested in
doing
not only vfx but you know kind of what
we're doing here like trying to take one
of your passions and make
an entertainment slash information
career out of it you know what advice
would you have for someone like that
i mean film school is a great place to
go
i mean i not because of the classes that
you're going to be taking because in my
classes we like
started off with the really obscure
abstract experimental stuff
it's like we didn't start with raiders
of the lost ark and work our way
forwards we started with like
the creme de la creme of art films and
worked our way backwards
which was a really strange way to do it
and i didn't get to pick up a camera in
any class until my last year of college
so my biggest piece of advice would be
to just not
wait for anybody to tell you to make a
movie and just i mean it's like
you've heard this advice from a million
youtubers over the years but just pick
up a camera
and start making movies don't worry
about spending money or anything
and honestly i feel like i did waste
not waste because it's valuable but i
spent a lot of time
learning how to make things look good
and sound good
and look realistic where i wish i had
been focusing that time more
on learning structure and storytelling
and screenwriting and that kind of thing
because you know you can have a movie
that looks amazing and sounds amazing
but if the story is not great then
nobody's going to want to watch it uh to
add on that i feel like
a lot of the value from like getting a
film degree or an art degree
is that it's you're getting all of the
theory getting all of like the why
things are this way why people implement
these strategies when it comes to art
or you know and structure and
storytelling and all that stuff whereas
like all the technical stuff that's best
learned on your own that's best learned
through
like just actually following a manual
and doing it
and and so it's like that's that's
probably why you don't
pick up a camera until the last year
because it's like i
i don't know there's a lot i mean i'm
saying it's like you should definitely
just
not consider that a film school is gonna
get you to
hold a camera that's something you have
to do on your own the film school is
there to tell you
why you're holding a camera right i mean
i don't know
you went to you got like a film minor or
art major
i had a double journey double major
that's what it is okay
i knew it was they're both on equal
footing also okay okay that's fair
that's okay
i double majored in film and uh fine art
fine art yeah right and that's one that
already sticks out in my head yeah the
fire degree is what
like gave me like a bunch of the wisdom
i have today i got some of it from my
film degree
for really only for two classes one of
which was kind of a [ __ ] class
but it was a fun class that like made
you think it was it was psychology in
film
and there was so much freud in that
class by the way freud while being a
famous psychologist
none of this [ __ ] is scientifically like
used today like it's all it's all made
up
it's entirely something it's looking at
the mind yeah it's all made up stuff
somebody trying to make it all
make sense and it's all you know nowhere
based on scientific theory these days
i mean there's you know some initial
like things that started the thought
process to where we are now and whatnot
but
anyways this film class like did way too
much quoting of freud because obviously
none of this stuff
applies to medical psychology but um
i'm speaking in broad generalizations
here i'm sure someone who has a
psychology degree is gonna chime in the
comments later
oh my god anyways but
that class still taught us to think
about things that you completely take
for granted when it comes to filmmaking
and start asking like
it's really the psychological
psychological function that you have
where it's like
at what point do you start ignoring the
borders of the screen
you know like do you ask yourself that
do you ever go like boy i wish the
screen was a little bit wider
like you don't you like the moment you
start watching tv you ignore the borders
and they go away
and there's all these kind of questions
of like how does that work how
psychologically what happens what
happens if
if you have eight shots in a row that
are all you know like shoulder mounted
head height shots
and your ninth shot is up high looking
down at your actors like a god's eye
view
what does that do psychologically
speaking like what does it trigger
inside of you
especially like to people that don't
study it like because people just watch
a movie right just you absorb it and
that's it
so what what are you tweaking in their
brain when you cut to that angle
that's different than all the other
angles um so they all say things you
know you look
it's yeah it was fascinating stuff but
like it was like it's very like
you know hocus pocus science at the same
time
but it was like one of two classes that
like really got me
like thinking about the function of film
and that was you know by then i was a
senior like my last semester and so then
i was out of school by that point
whereas i got a lot more of that kind of
stuff from my art
degree um you know everything from like
artist statements to having a purpose
you know the craftsmanship like they
definitely don't really teach you
craftsmanship
in in film school i mean they do in some
obviously and they do in some art
classes but like
you're going to get you know there's no
point in going to college to learn how
to use adobe premiere or adobe after
effects
it's very good that's not what college
is for and
there's especially no point in going
like 150 to 200 000
debt just to learn after effects but if
you're going to be
going to meet people and like trying to
learn new perspectives and broaden your
points of view on things like
it could be it can be very valuable for
that but you know
yeah yeah that was the biggest takeaway
i got from college was just having that
experience of moving away from home
and learning about myself and
broadening broadening my horizons as a
person so i feel like that
yes mutual exploration no but that was
definitely the
most valuable part so i i don't think
college is for everybody but i think
getting out of the house and moving
somewhere else is for everybody and then
also like you know having roommates or
flatmates or you know
living in a dorm and just having that
social experience i think is
important yeah yeah because you still
need to interact with people for the
rest of your life so you might as well
get good at it
yeah i mean look at clint look at how
awful he turned out he didn't go to
college
yoga school in bali which is just sick
though clint did get up out of the house
and go and and try
you know yeah he's done a bunch of
traveling like he pursued the same
things that one would
experience in college but he did it
without college which is entirely
something you can do like you don't need
to go to college um but at the same time
you should enrich yourself as a person
and grow yourself as a person no matter
what you
do um you know that stuff's good to do
my one advice for people who are
listening to this and thinking about
getting into film school or
you know switching careers or all kind
of stuff you know
my one piece of advice would be to try
not to go into debt
for it because especially if it's a
passion-driven thing
because at some point you need to start
turning it into a career
and it's really hard to make that push
from it being a passion to a thing that
actually gives you a living
if you're having to pay off 500 bucks or
a thousand bucks a month in the process
especially at the beginning you're gonna
be doing a lot of it for free as you
just try to find other people who are
as passionate about it as you are and
then after a while you'll all still have
to grow as artists
and network and eventually find the
people that have the money in it or find
a way to make money yourself which takes
time because you have to build up
you know an audience and people that are
willing to purchase your product
um and to do all that yeah you need time
and it's hard to find the time if you
got the thumb
of like debt just pushing down on you
the whole time so that's
that's the one thing that like i caution
people when they like talk about going
to like usc to study film it's like
you know if you have a way to handle the
debt we got scholarships or something
you know savings whatever it might be
cool but you're gonna have a really hard
time
making good on that like film degree and
finding yourself as an artist
if you are having to pay off a bunch of
debt in the process if you have a
mortgage basically
right out of film school you're gonna
have a hard time so yeah
yeah no i think that's really good
advice i mean i remember when i got out
of grad
or undergraduate and uh i had
a little bit of debt and my first thing
was like
you know oh i gotta go get a job because
i gotta i gotta pay
for this college um and it and it took
me from
you know thinking about like okay what's
the best long-term career strategy here
to just okay boom
this is my job i gotta go do it um and
that only lasted for so long before i
you know couldn't didn't want to do it
anymore um
and and eventually i went and got myself
more debt but
at the time we're building that debt or
i was building that debt we were
building a business too
so you know they worked hand in hand and
eventually
you know that all came uh came
due and and you know it is what it is
but um
yeah that's a i think that's important
for sure like
if you can avoid going into debt you'll
be you'll be better off
if you're already in debt because of it
don't worry though you know there's
there's still ways to do it and there's
ways to slice it
you have to work through it but that's
cool everyone's got to work through it
right
you pay your dues at some point yeah
exactly that's the don't don't be
confused with
with that don't confuse that with not
having to pay your dues because that's
that's true in every
everything you do no matter what you do
yep exactly and that's how you become a
youtuber
all right all right well that's it
that's of what to do with your life
uh thanks for listening and uh if you
guys want to really hear us rant
consider
a website subscription corridor
digital.com it's uh
way cooler than watching us on youtube
um
because uh it allows us to make more
shows and more content there's exclusive
shows on there
uh x-ray content x-rated peter's
x-rated corner all the plastic yeah it's
one
we made it into a series yep we made it
into a whole series
um so go on and check that out uh it's
3.99 a month
uh and you get points that you can put
into shows to
uh tell us what you want to see us make
yeah
all right good stuff yeah thanks for
watching listening everybody
yeah watching or listening whatever you
like so long everybody